so I recently had a question from
someone that wanted to know what would
be better to use coconut oil or olive
oil so I want to go through the some of
the differences but they're both really
really good oils but have slightly
different purposes
so let's start with olive oil okay olive
oil it's heavy on the omega-6 fatty
acids which typically will cause
inflammation but olive oil is one of the
only oils being omega-6 that will not
cause inflammation it's an
anti-inflammatory so it's 78 percent
monounsaturated coconut oil is 92%
saturated fat and honestly saturated fat
is not a bad thing okay
it's very stable it will not increase
bad cholesterol it will not clot your
arteries it really has no side effects
despite being a saturated fat it's not
the type of fat that will cause heart
attacks or insulin resistance or
anything like that
okay now olive oil is great to put on
your salad it has tons and tons of
phytonutrients I mean a list is very
very long so its phytonutrients are
those extra nutrients that give you
extra health benefits that go beyond
vitamins and minerals there's not hardly
any minerals or protein in olive oil
actually there's no protein there's very little
vitamins except there's some vitamin E
and there's no minerals it's mainly
healthy fatty acids which are essential
that means your body can't make them but
it needs them so it has Oleic acid 83%
linolenic acid 21% palmitic acid 20% and
there's there's several other ones as
well so it's healthy in that it gives
you these fatty acids that are essential
but the biggest benefit for elavil
is the heart benefit supporting a
healthy heart I believe the reason for
that is because it stabilizes blood
sugars it helps to reduce insulin which
is underneath our problem but it has
some a direct effects on the heart
itself as far as healing the inside of
the artery as well and not to mention
some vitamin E but there are other
benefits as well one being an anti
like I mentioned before now coming over
the coconut oil coconut oil is really
good for your immune system it has
something called lauric acid
lauric acid is high in breast milk and
coconut oil okay so you have to make
sure that the quality is there
but lauric acid is really good to
support an immune system anti microbial
you can put a drop of garlic oil and put
it in your ear to help ear infections
but you can do also do the same thing
with olive oil you can put a drop of
garlic oil in the olive oil and just put
a drop in your ear and that will
actually help your infections as well
because it supports and protects the
flora the friendly bacteria and just
attacks the the pathogenic microbes so
it's pretty cool
coconut oil also has phytonutrients I
believe olive oil has more but it still
has numerous phytonutrients you can put
in your coffee okay and you can blend it
up into it like a nice keto coffee
it also will increase HDL and lower LDL
it's great to as a part of a ketogenic
diet to give you energy you can put in
all sorts of recipes for keto bombs and
again both of these have their benefits
I wouldn't even say one is better than
the other I would consume them both but
they do slightly different things
alright thanks for watching
hey you know what I just wanted to say
thank you for watching these videos you
made it this far
I appreciate your attention and your
precious time